[Music]
even you ask a wonderful question how
many galaxies are there and this is
something that we actually don't know
the answer to but I can tell you a
wonderful story about what we do know so
let me first talk about what a galaxy is
and a galaxy is a family of stars but it
usually in the hundreds of billions of
stars we live in a galaxy called the
Milky Way and there are about 500
billion stars we think in the Milky Way
galaxy galaxies are absolutely huge the
Milky Way galaxy is about a hundred
thousand light years across and that's
not really a number I can get my mind
around seeing as one light year is about
6 trillion miles so our single galaxy is
a hundred thousand times 6 trillion
miles across it's absolutely huge that
the best analogy I know is that if you
think about the Sun the Sun is a giant
thing that the Sun is so big you could
fit a million earths inside it it's
really really big and if we made the Sun
the size of the dot of an eye so so
pretend that the Sun is only the size of
like you know take a regular page of a
book look at the dot of an eye the
summer that big how big would our one
Milky Way galaxy be it'd be about the
size of the earth so that's how big a
single galaxy is if the Sun were the dot
of an eye the Milky Way galaxy would be
roughly the size of our planet now how
many galaxies do we know of and this is
a wonderful result from the Hubble Space
Telescope the Hubble Space Telescope
decided to try to answer that question
and what it did is it looked at an area
of the sky that as far as we know was
blank it was just black we couldn't see
many stars there we didn't see any
galaxies there and it decided to take a
very very deep distant look at the
universe now the way the Hubble Space
Telescope and any camera works is it
works kind of like a light bucket you
can actually open up the eyes of the
telescope and tell it to just keep
staring and the longer it stares the
fainter and more distant objects you can
see for those of you that like
photography it's called doing a time
exposure you leave your camera open for
a certain amount of time and you can see
fainter and fainter things
well incredibly the Hubble Space
Telescope kept its
is open on this one little part of the
sky for more than a month and it just
let any light come and build up this
beautiful image and what we discovered
is that in this empty part of the sky
empty we say we counted over five
thousand galaxies five thousand galaxies
we didn't even know were there they were
just so faint we'd never seen them
before when we finally had a sensitive
enough telescope up in space and we were
able to keep it staring at a tiny little
part of the sky for a month
five thousand galaxies turned out to be
hiding there that we'd never seen so how
much of the sky was this tiny little
part that the Hubble Space Telescope
looked at so let's go back to the dot of
an eye so so think about the dot of an
eye in a book and now hold that book at
arm's length it's a tiny little point
you can almost barely see a dot of an
eye held at arm's length that's how much
of the sky the Hubble Space Telescope
counted five thousand galaxies in and if
you do the statistics if you take that
little dot of the sky and by the way
we've done this we've taken other deep
images in different regions of the sky
and we get about the same count of
galaxies anywhere we look if you do the
math tiny little dot all over the sky
five thousand galaxies in each dot there
are actually several trillion galaxies
that we can see with the hubble space
telescope if we had the time to observe
the entire sky so we know that there are
several trillion galaxies that the
hubble space telescope can see but is
that really the number is that how many
galaxies there really are the universe
we think is far larger than we're able
to see right now
so we're actually building telescopes
that are so powerful the James Webb
Space Telescope we hope will launch in
the year 2020 and that will be so
powerful it will be able to see every
single galaxy
all the way back to the beginning of
time so it will be able to see so far
away that the light has taken thirteen
billion years to get to us and we should
be able to see at any part of the sky
every galaxy that's ever formed in the
history of the universe is that the
answer is that how many galaxies there
are well I ask you to consider there's
something that astronomers call the
observable universe
and that is that if we take a telescope
and we look in every direction around us
there is in fact a limit to how far we
can see and that's because the universe
is not infinitely old we think the
universe began about 13.8 billion years
ago with the Big Bang so we can only see
as far out as there's been time for
light to get to us so we see in every
direction on the sky out to a distance
where we're looking back say about 13
billion years and that's wonderful but
does that mean that's how big the
universe is no the universe must be much
larger than that it's just that there
hasn't been time for light to get to us
from the rest of the universe if the
universe is around for another 20
billion years we will see farther and
farther and farther out into the true
universe we have no idea how big the
universe really is we can only see the
part of it where there's been time for
light to travel to us the universe is
not a sphere centered on us that would
be very very strange
that's just how far we can see in every
direction since the beginning of time so
what's the real answer how many galaxies
are there and this gets to one of the
most amazing things that we don't know
and that is what is the size of the
universe for all we know the universe
could be infinite it may be that the
real answer is if there an infinite
number of galaxies space never ends and
there are galaxies throughout an
infinite universe or maybe the universe
isn't infinite maybe there really is
some vast shape to it that we're not
aware of yet just like how we're
standing on a spherical earth right now
but it seems flat to us because we can
only actually walk around a little part
of it at once it could be that the
universe has a larger shape and maybe it
even has boundaries maybe there really
isn't answer to how big the universe is
in the time the universe has existed
there hasn't been time for light to
travel to us from the farthest reaches
of the universe so right now we honestly
have no idea how many galaxies there are
[Music]